[Music]
agr let's go
1960.
oh chilly scandinavian
okay scandy well we know how to play
against the scanning we take it we got
knight c3
okay queen d8
queen eight is the john bartholomew
setup this is a move which has gained in
popularity recently it's a very solid
system the best way to play against the
system is in a very very straightforward
chest first we should occupy the center
with our pawn and then we should develop
naturally and actively
we should develop naturally and actively
what does that mean well we should start
by playing d4 of course
then we play knight f3 bishop c4 blah
blah blah
knight f3
h6 that's already bad completely
unnecessary movement we can try to
punish it we can try to punish it by
playing in a very principled manner
um so
what do i mean by that
well we can
we should start by playing bishop c4
and aiming at the f7 pawn we can also
try to play 95
95 here is an interesting move but i
like bishop c4 develop the bishop aim at
the pawn and if he goes z6 that's ooh
this is flirting with disaster flirting
with disaster how why is it flirting
with disaster
i mean bishop f5 without e6 now we're
aiming at f7
oh we should totally play the yeah
definitely knight e5
and look this is serious e6
this is serious
let me think
there's multiple tempting moves here
i'm going to teach you guys a really
cool tactical idea
not g4
g4 is not dangerous for black don't put
one move items do not succumb to one
vitus
g4 bishop h7 doesn't do anything
i'm going to play a move which looks
wrong for several reasons
but i'm going to play it
and then well no actually i'm not i
think how do we want to do this there's
so many tempting moves here like i don't
know what to turn to
the move that i'm debating about playing
is queen f3
the move that i'm debating about playing
is queen f3 but maybe we should just
castle maybe we should be russian
and disciplined and just castle and
forget about everything crazy
queen h5 is interesting you know queen
h5 but queen h5 he'll play g6
when h5 he'll play gc i don't really
understand the follow-up after g6
the thing is after queen f3
okay i'll play it anyway i will go on
record and say it's a mistake but i'll
play it anyway in the hopes that he
allows us to execute the tactic
i see that he can take on d4 and after
queen takes d4 i did have a follow-up in
mind which is really cool
okay so he allows the tactic
there's a god in the sky what tactic am
i talking about
what tactic am i talking about and in
order to find this tactic you have to
break down break it down between
component parts
of course you still have to detect the
pressure that we're putting on f7
the second thing you have to say is well
okay if the king lands on f7 the pawn on
e6 is going to be pimped
therefore knight takes f7 king takes f7
and queen takes f5 tactics are pretty
logical when you come to think about it
now we win a pawn the king is in
shambles we're completely winning and
this concept exists in many different
types of openings not just in this
opening i can show you 15 examples of
this knight f7 queen f5 business yeah so
again i know it's scary because our
queen is hanging and we're we seem to be
dependent on this very tenuous tactical
device to keep our queen protected but
remember if you get scared you can
always move the queen back
it's not like he can get rid of the pin
and then simultaneously take the queen
the bishop is completely safe on c4 if
anything it can drop back to b3
and just you know if you want to squeeze
the most out of the speedrun when i do a
tactic like this just sort of file it
away maybe even write it down or
photograph it on your phone just keep a
keep a running record of interesting
tactical ideas
because before you know it i guarantee
you you will have a chance to apply it
okay queen d6 is like a tilt move it
walks right into something else
what does this walk into this walks into
a development move with tempo
yeah put it in alicia study whatever you
prefer
get the bishop out with temple again and
now we're not moving the queen we don't
need to move our queen our bishop is
perfectly capable of defending it
yeah then we're going to castle and try
to put a rook on one and smash through
on e6 this is already essentially
resignable what makes matters worse for
black is that he can never drop the king
back to g8 because that blunders the
pawn on e6
queen e7
where should we castle it really doesn't
matter castle in king side queenside is
essentially the same thing
but just because we're attacking and
we're in that mood
i'm going to castle queenside
i feel like we're in that we're in that
zone
why not 94 yeah 94 would have been a
good well
no 94 would have not been a good move
g6 is a good move that is the only way
to stay alive
but not for long where should our queen
go
where should our queen go
well let's think about it
okay
you know from previous speed runs that
i've talked about the queen as being a
supporting actress sometimes people are
always tempted to play queen e5 in this
position right but queen e5 is
counterproductive because when the queen
is in the middle of the attack when it's
at the front lines that's like you know
you have napoleon bonaparte at your
disposal and you send napoleon you know
to fight on the front lines you want
your war general to be behind enemy
lines directing traffic
queen e5 walks right into knight bd7
right it walks right into a development
movement we have to move the queen again
we want to keep the queen on h3 where
it's still doing something right it's
it's pressuring the e6 pawn but it's
very invulnerable if you want more
information on this i wrote a chess.com
article a couple years ago literally
called queen the supporting actress
which is composed of examples from
attacks where the queen was essentially
kept
behind
behind the attack
rather than in the middle of things okay
king g7 is very impatient
and it blunders the e6 pawn which thank
you very much we will gladly take
free pawn absolutely free pawn and also
like black's position collapses bishop
e5 is a great follow-up in this position
in order to pin the knight to the to the
king
rookie one also rookie one is great too
yeah anything is winning and yasser is
the originator of this concept he was
the one who told me about it
yeah black is just totally busted here
totally busted okay
so we can still play bishop e5 because
in the event of a trade our rook on d1
gets free
but in the interest of playing
disciplined russian attacking chess
let's get our final piece into the game
let's get our final rook into the game
right he won setting up an x-ray against
the queen
really does not matter how you play here
as long as you're making
decent attacking moves
and you should because they're easy to
make then you're fine
okay a couple of possibilities here once
again we could play bishop e5 which
would be an excellent move
because knight takes c5 would be
unthinkable but the moment queen d8 is
played the first thing that catches my
eye is the x-ray i am obsessed with
x-rays x-rays are valuable they can be
exploited how can it be exploited well
it can only be exploited if we get rid
of the d-pawn
can we get rid of it we absolutely can
we can push d5 this is a typical
attacking motif
and if black plays c5 which i think he's
going to play we can shove this pawn all
the way down to d6 in order to prevent
the bishop from ever moving again
well it's an x-ray because the rook is
sort of staring at the queen through a
bunch of other pieces
oh this is i mean wow
okay
it takes d5
no bishop e5 was just as strong i mean
everything is winning here
feel like i need to keep keep repeating
this that when you're in a position
that's this winning
there are going to be often four or five
possible attacking continuations
you don't want to obsess over like okay
i played a move you're looking at it
especially people on youtube who don't
have the chance to participate in a live
chat you might be looking at this and
saying why didn't daniel play this other
move that looks completely winning
don't pull your hair out over that
because chances are that move is also
winning it's just a matter of taste i
chose something else
although in other cases of course your
move might be wrong or even my move
might be wrong that's also possible
okay knight takes we'll take with the
rook we're completely crushing here it's
over
and it's just
demolition
i'll open x marks that's what i play on
the screen the speed run
okay bishop b7 we can literally take any
piece here and win
but probably since the two knights are
defending each other the best thing to
do is to take the knight
and then take the knight with a rook
because if he takes with his knight then
we take the queen
okay
this is easy
take the queen
this is all elementary my dear watson we
can get our queen to e6 bishop b5 to
trade the last remaining pair bishops is
good
rookie six rook takes f6 is fine i mean
really anything is winning here
principal pronounced paid out paid off
it's a done deal trapper city you can be
freaking
deep stockfish 800 and you're losing
yeah the simplest move here is bishop e5
just trading off the last remaining
defender of the bishop of the king
and the point of bishop e5 is ultimately
we want to get a rook
to the seventh rank which is the fastest
path to checkmate which is what we're
gonna do right now ricky seven check
i'm playing quickly here because it it's
so winning that at this level you should
be very comfortable in converting these
types of positions
okay so we have several possible moves
but we should probably the simplest is
to keep the rook on the seventh rank
rook h7
and then queen takes h6 is the immediate
mate threat
the other one being queen a3 followed by
queen e7 infiltrating to the seventh
rank of the queen
yeah i mean the position is completely
resignable
yeah so now we go for our secondary idea
getting this queen into e7 with
checkmate along the seventh rank
again by the way using the whole board
again by the way using the whole board
not just fixating on two
files
but really using the whole board you
know as your as a trampoline to get your
pieces where you want them to go
it's just good practice to physically
okay you look at both sides of the board
the queen side nothing is going on there
but you can use it as a springboard to
move to the king's side for your heavy
pieces
take stakes
okay checkmate
all right cool stuff so this is a pretty
simple game and that's why i don't
really recommend the scandi to you know
1400 rated players because again it
violates certain principles
and i would say you should be a minimum
of around 16 1700 before you can even
consider it that would be my philosophy
so h6 is a mistake the move here i think
and you should ask john
but i think black should play bishop g4
in order to prevent the knight from
coming to e5 and bishop c4 should always
be met with e6 to blunt the bishop
yeah bishop i mean h6 is a waste of time
and when black is down this much in
developing he cannot afford a waste of
time
okay bishop f5
95 e6 so why is queen f3 wrong the
reason it's wrong
is queen takes d4 now white has two
interesting possibilities here who can
name both of them
one of them is a developing move that
keeps the tension one of them is the
tactical approach which you guys already
know by now
yeah the the slow move is bishop f4 and
what i was really worried about here is
the move knight to d7
well why is it dangerous you might ask
well it's dangerous because the bishop
on c4 is a type two undefended piece
and our position starts to collapse a
little bit i mean if you play knight
takes d7 yeah this is possible for white
and white is a big development advantage
but after queen takes c4 i just wasn't
entirely convinced in this position
although maybe after we castle things
things are still very very good
so that's one approach the other
approach is to still play knight takes
f7 i mean king takes f7 then we take on
f5
and if queen takes c4 we take the rook
on h8 now you might say well isn't this
really good for white white is up in
exchange well i'm worried that this
knight is going to get trapped
and after something like g5 followed by
bishop g7 i i don't know if i would want
these complications given that we had
such a nice position so kavita proposed
this i think castling is really the
mature approach to the position but i
wanted to show you guys this tactical
idea
after which all of this is game over
and to prove my point i guess i said i
can find examples of this from different
openings i'm going to make a quick quick
search
for this
so here we go from 1996.
this is a karo khan
see four panel of attack bishop f5 you
can see where this is going black plays
dc which is bad e6 is the move here
knight f3 knight e5
queen f3
white plays this perfectly bishop d6
boom
we have five and actually here white
plays knight e4 which is a move that we
wanted to play and then knight g5 check
and look at this is beautiful queen
takes c6 chick and that white simply
castles
castling out of the pin the point is
rookie six there's 96 of the fork
and white goes on to win the game
with a crushing attack maybe not the
best play by white
white sacrifices a piece maybe
unnecessarily but
okay ultimately white white wins the
game
yeah not the best conversion by white
but you can kind of see the point you
know these
these things that i play are are real
they're real things
and they they occur in real games
and that's why it's important to review
games because you accumulate these the
knowledge of these ideas that you can
then apply to your own games
yeah the rest is very easy queen h3
supporting actress
and then we take e6
we blast through in the center we would
have played d6 and he played c5
and the rest was very very
straightforward
so at this level we're still at the
level where when players get you know
players don't know
certain relatively rudimentary attacking
concepts or tactical concepts and a lot
of those just win games straight away so
just file this away into your sort of
mental directory
and uh yeah remember i just don't
recommend the scandi
uh until you're 17 until you're you've
fully mastered the basics and you're
ready to sort of branch out a little bit
have a great night everybody
i'll see you guys soon
[Music]
you